Hillary Clinton will win the presidency
she will be the first female president
in America what would you expect from
being madam president when in America
it's not the president it's an
institution so of course she'll make
history as a woman I have I'm I'm I
wouldn't say I'm happy but I hope that
she can really prove to be the woman
that I think of that but but I doubt I
doubt that very much because again she
has to play the political game within
the American institution in the Americas
system and she has been playing it in
the past and she will be playing in the
future but nevertheless at least I'm
sure that for sure would like to see the
splendor modern sir trampled in her in
an America but for us hoping that really
she as a woman and understanding that
she's powerful advocate of woman
indistinct what countries are jazz been
doing great warning that field so I do
that we really can see a woman that can
have an impact on the global chaos
that's going on now today and that she
brings the good people and that she's
surrounded with people that have really
intelligent new vision about this world
and that she really has her own and she
walks her folks and but I was in America
last week I was New York and to be very
honest with you the debate is very
fierce it is splintered you know have
Benghazi that she has also a lot of a
lot of you know I'm saying
history behind him so I want to wait and
see because we were happy with mr. Obama
when he came to power but then he
disappointed us heavily disappointed us
so I don't know if his politician and
this age being trapped in this political
system that's bringing chaos to the
globe leaving us two more more more
blood you know and I hope also to see
that these international institutions
keep their promises and changed these
people and bring the unit to the
forefront I'm for the younger generation
all in the end of generation can bring
the innovative ideas is fantastic what
you would are trying to do Olivia
fantastic but who's giving them the
chance was listening to them neither the
woman were all away because we think if
you think it incorrectly of course
you're a woman if you think if you're
correct just well you have their own
recipe they thought they told me here
and they you many people don't want to
meet me I'm too much straightforward I'm
too much of an activist I'm not a
diplomat No thank you I don't want to be
a diplomat what's the diploma to sit
listening to you in something my people
in suffering my country you want me to
be quiet now I'm not interested in is
staying in Brussels still be there you
of course I'm always be hopefully
cooperating with other departments for
the benefits of my country the EU but if
it's done wrong noritz no i don't
that I will be happy to I be with within
this international separate I've been
with very close within the UN community
for 13 years I know the corridors of
this UN system inside that they have to
change there must be pressure
internationally they have to make the
game's over they cannot continue to
really contribute to this world disaster
in the globe they have an under the
european and the Western taxpayer they
are the one who have responsibility to
stop them and go sooner